[Music]
this morning on the dish chef julia
sullivan a daughter of the south
sullivan studied at the culinary
institute of america in new york's
hudson valley before working at some of
the city's top kitchens five years ago
she moved home to nashville and opened
henrietta red an oyster bar and
restaurant named after her grandparents
but henrietta red is a far cry from the
nashville restaurants our grandparents
would remember
we'll go in with the tip right into this
back hinge here okay
julia sullivan knows how to unlock a
treasure if you hit the right spot it's
kind of like just jiggling a key a
little bit it's part of her key to
success you can just kind of ease into
it
oh there we go okay and then you'll just
use your knife to scrape the muscle off
the top of the shell i think i actually
did okay yeah you did great and what you
really want to look for is these like
full intact bellies you see
sullivan serves up a dozen varieties of
oysters each night we can go ahead and
taste this guy
the hallmark of her restaurant henrietta
red when was the first time you had an
oyster do you remember i think i was
around nine okay and there was a
restaurant
called the rainbow key in a strip mall
on white ridge road
and good memory florida themed
and my dad he loved oysters i tried one
i can't say that i held it down
sullivan has more than made up for lost
time
returning to her hometown of nashville
[Music]
to open her first restaurant as both
co-owner and head chef in 2013 i feel
like the food was a lot heavier there
was a lot more emphasis on southern
cooking it felt very masculine and sort
of you know there's just whiskey on the
back bar and dark colors and the in the
decor
and i wanted to open a place and feel
like the space and the food was meant
for
my friends and me which is what you'll
find at henrietta red including a wood
fired bread served with rich anchovy
butter and wood roasted thai green curry
or salsa matcha oysters
a little spicy little smell like a
little bit of kick now
does the green curry one have kik it has
a little kick yeah it has a lots of
serrano peppers
lemongrass
curry paste i might be i hate to say
this i might be more on the match yeah
yeah there's a smoked trout salad with
house made kimchi style ferment and
purple daikon this is like artwork i
don't want to touch it and even an
appetizer inspired by her dad's old
go-to starter called poppy's caviar he
made a version that was sour cream a
really improvised scallion vinaigrette
and then typically like really cheap
salty fish row from the grocery store
aisle that comes in those little jars
right and so we wanted like to mimic
that because it's so enjoyable kind of
hits all the notes on the palette
henrietta red's version includes
homemade saltines and paddle fish caviar
that comes from just outside nashville
what does dad think of this one i think
he's just very kind of tickled to be on
the menu but sullivan traces her
culinary inspiration to another family
on another continent thanks to a high
school study abroad program in france
and i lived with a family that had three
teenage kids who really couldn't care
less that i was there
and so i spent a lot of time with the
mother and the mother had a beautiful
backyard garden and would pull food from
it for us to cook for lunch and dinner
most days and so really that was kind of
the first interest i had in growing food
and cooking food and then kind of grew
and evolved from there especially when
sullivan chose tulane university in new
orleans for college
yeah i don't know if there's a better
food city than new orleans in some ways
yes i think actually i blame my career
path on going to college there
there are a lot of different things
people blame new orleans for that's a
good thing
everything there is about cultural
heritage the restaurants are 100 years
old they all have stories and family
history and i just fell in love with it
and so i started hostessing and then
eventually cooking as a college student
before going on to culinary school
that led to an internship for julio four
egg with dan barber and blue hill at
stone barns followed by a job under
thomas keller at manhattan's per se
but it was at franny's an italian
restaurant in brooklyn where sullivan
says she really cooked for the first
time
they just had a style of cooking that
was so
infused with
warmth and soul and flavor and each dish
only had
really four or five ingredients and so
it was kind of about like sussing out
the best qualities of all those
ingredients and and just letting them
shine and i think it just really opened
my eyes to so much that was outside of
sort of the classical technique
at henrietta red sullivan brought it all
together a variety of technique and
tastes
the sausage is another thing we've
always kept on the menu for the meat
eaters there's a sausage served this
season with orange yogurt and pharaoh
salad oh that's so good yeah that's a
really nice one very orange kind of
fresh oh yeah
vegetarian options include this gnocchi
adorned by melted squash with pepita
seeds and a parmesan broth things just
taste better when they're in season so
if you're using really good ingredients
you don't have to do that much to
manipulate it all helping sullivan and
henrietta redd stand out in a city no
longer known
simply for its music
the fact that we've kind of become a
standby in this scene is pretty amazing
and through a pandemic yes
yeah through a crazy time and i think
that yeah i think that people have come
to sort of know and understand our style
and what we do here and and that is
special what do you hope somebody leaves
here with you know i hope feeling like
they
just had a good time when you're in here
and the dining room's full and there's
music on and it's the right vibe it kind
of feels like a party those are the best
nights for us where it's busy and loud
and they kind of
felt taken care of
and we helped take care of you yay
poppy's caviar which is truly delicious
again that house-made saltine the
homemade
saltine and the paddle fish paddlefish
from the nashville nashville area what
does that mean what do you mean from the
nashville area that's where they get the
tablet that's where they get the caviar
yeah no i know but from a river i
thought it was from an ocean not this
this caviar is from near nashville but
all the oysters that she brings in it's
literally you know gulf coast it's the
east coast the west coast and all of
that
thanks to the beauty of fedex and
technology oh my gosh it's delicious
right oh man so good yes so so good